Voiceover:So we've plotted two
complex numbers right over here
on this argand diagram.
And what I want to think about is
what if we defined a
third complex number, C,
as being equal to the complex number, A,
minus the complex number, B.
What is C going to look like
if we were to write it as just a
sum of its real and imaginary parts
and what would it look like
on this argand diagram?
So let's just first think about this.
So C is...
Let me do that yellow color.
C is equal to A,
which is the same thing as
six plus two i, minus B.
And what is B?
B is two minus i.
So when we're subtracting anything,
we can distribute this negative sign.
And so this would be the same thing...
This would be equivalant
to six plus two i,
minus two, and then
distributing the negative
on a negative i, that's
going to be a positive i.
Plus i, just like that.
And now this is going to be equal to...
I'll do it right over here.
This is going to be equal to...
We can add the real parts right over here.
We have six minus two.
And so that's going to be four.
And then we can add the two i to the i.
Which is going to be three i's.
Plus four, plus three i.
And that is the complex number C.
Let's see why that actually makes sense
when we visualize A and B as vectors.
So this is B.
When we do A minus B,
that's essentially the same thing as
A plus negative B.
So what's negative B going to be equal to?
Negative B is going to be equal to
negative two plus i.
I just multiplied all the
terms by negative one.
So what does that look like?
Let's see, negative two plus i
gets us right over there.
And we see we've essentially just flipped
this vector over the origin.
So this right over here is negative B.
That is negative B.
And we've already seen,
if you're adding two things,
we're going to add A to negative B.
So we've plotted A so that
its tail's at the origin
and its head is right over here.
And then we can take
the tail of negative B,
put it right over here
and then if we just shift it over,
it goes two to the left and one up,
it gets to that point right over here.
It gets to this point right over there.
This vector is another way to visualize
negative B as a vector.
And so where our new head is,
once we've put the tail
of negative B here,
where our new head is going to be
the head of our vector C.
So C is going to be this
vector right over here.
C can be visualized as this
And we see that is one, two, three, four,
that is four plus one, two, three i.
We see that right over there.
So on one level,
it's kind of straight forward,
manipulating expressions
and just recognizing
that you can only add the
imaginary parts to the imaginary parts
and the real parts to the real parts.
And if you want to visualize
it on an argand diagram,
it really is analogous
to subtracting B from A
is equivalent to adding
the negative of B to A.